[Music]
we fight first yeah we're super excited
about season four it's coming soon yeah
we don't want to spoil anything though
dropping december 31st global on netflix
so tune in we'll see you at the
tournament all right
but that's not all this cast is
celebrating hey e.t come with us we're
going to go get a birthday card for 10.
turn in the big 2 3 2 3 23 sort of like
you know how we look now
we teamed up with the og karate kid
stars and hallmark to find the perfect
gift
oh yeah look at this you just wow look
at that you just scan this to your phone
you could send a personal video greeting
that's cool man yeah you keep it forever
you can post it on social he could tag
us he better tag us that's why we're
doing this right damn right tanner's
other co-stars also took part in the
video greeting card check out the
surprise hey what's up buddy happy
birthday boy from both of us
and many many many more but i was my
idea so yeah okay i was the one that
said let's get him a card
i picked out this amazing card for you
ralph helped but i want to be the very
first one to say happy birthday buddy
much love
i just wanted to wish you a very very
happy birthday
so happy birthday my friend 75
76
hey tanner
uh hope you're having a happy birthday
happy 23rd birthday i love you brother
oh this is awesome guys
thank you so much
happy birthday many more